amum brother I have a question regarding
the me if a woman says that I forgive
the me to my husband is it valid and
secondly if this is not valid then what
if the man dies without paying me to his
wife there are two question that if a
wife wants to forgive the M can she do
it and what if the May is not given or
if the m is not forgiven if the person
dies what happens sister as question
number one is concerned that if a wife
wants to forgive the her she can but it
should be of a fre will it should not be
a pressure because see when a Mah is
given it can be given of three types the
best is that the m is given at the time
of nikah the complete amount whatever
the amount is five TOA gold 10 TOA gold
10 g gold whatever it is best is to give
on the spot if the person says no I
cannot give on the spot the second
option is he can give part at the time
of ncah and part later on maybe few days
later on few weeks later on few years
later on no problem and third option is
that the May has been already stipulated
but because doesn't have money at that
point he says it is deferred I will give
it to you later even that's allowed so
if the husband gives Mar before the nah
the question doesn't arises if he gives
part and part later on or if he says
that full Mary gives later on it's
allowed now after that if the wife wants
to forgive she can forgive she said I
don't want the may I give it back to you
I don't request she has full right but
it should be of free will it can't be on
the day of nikah that the husband forced
and say that see now I told you I'll
give after you forgive it this otherwise
there'll be a problem and the wife is
forced to say okay by after K this does
happen in some places which is totally
un Islamic it is Haram if the wife out
of the Free Will wants to forgive she
can't forgive because that is her
property me is her property she has full
right over it even if the husband gives
me before the nikah and if the wife
wants to give it back to the husband she
can gift it now it's her property
there's no rule in Islam that a wife
cannot gift to the husband anything she
can give double the amount of M back to
the husband if she wants why not if she
has own property so that is her free
will but she cannot be forced into it so
a wife out of Free Will can forgive them
hair but she should not be forced by the
husband or by the in-laws perfectly
allowed now if the husband doesn't give
them hair out of any reason whether the
wife hasn't forgiven or whether the
husband said he'll give it after a few
years and he expires before giving it so
the rule is whatever his property
is first the Mah has to be given to the
wife and then the property divided
therefore the Quran said that if there
are any debts any liabilities for first
that has to be given from the balance
property so person dies and has taken
loan from a friend of 100 lakh
rupees or 100,000 rupees whatever it is
so first that money has to be returned
even the mayor is sort of a balance that
the husband is supposed to give so this
me amount from the balanced property of
that man has to be given to the wife if
there any loans any debts which he has
to give to business partners or friends
or any other relativ should be given and
then whatever the balance properties
that has to be divided according to the
Sharia and then the wife also gets the
share from the property if she has
children she gets one8 if she has no
children she gets
1/4 so she gets a mar separately then
the period that is
there even that has to be taken care
from the wealth of the husband and after
that whatever is balanced so she gets a
share of the mar if it hasn't been given
she gets the share of the period for
seeing to whatever her is there for that
4 months and 10 days if the husband has
died and after that whatever amount is
balanced after paying liability of the
other people that is divided and she
gets 1/4 share if there are no children
1/8 of the balanced property and
inheritance if there are children hope
the answer the question is